on the bonus show today we're going to
be talking about the conviction of the
Mexican drug lord el chapo and I was
waiting for it last night I knew someone
in Trump's inner circle would do it and
it happened
Sarah Huckabee Sanders Donald Trump's
press secretary suggested that we really
need a wall because El Chapo is a bad
guy and is from Mexico and Sarah
Huckabee Sanders tweeted about this last
night and I replied and my reply made it
into a bunch of articles written about
this she tweeted that El Chapo's reign
of terror is now over and that the
threat from violent drug cartels is real
so thus we must secure our border and I
wrote back lol he was arrested in Mexico
and our law enforcement brought him into
the United States of America what would
a wall have done the UK independent
ended up featuring my tweet Newsweek
ended up writing about the fact that I
responded in this way to Sarah Huckabee
Sanders and as I say in in my tweet he
was captured in Mexico by Mexican law
enforcement and extradited to the United
States so the idea that a wall would
have stopped him is silly but people are
very ignorant about this so one common
response that I got on Twitter was well
come on David it's not about El Chapo
personally he was trafficking drugs to
the United States of America and the
wall would have stopped that well no it
wouldn't have because as we know now
most drugs are coming into the United
States not just over the unprotected
border but through actual ports of entry
it's being smuggled through legal ports
of entry so again a wall wouldn't have
helped there but then it gets even
wackier because El Chapo happens to be
known for escaping with tunnels and for
trafficking drugs with tunnels that go
underneath the border so once again a
wall wouldn't do anything about that
this is a guy who has used tunnels and
boats and planes and it makes this focus
on the wall which we knew would
coming from someone in Trump's inner
circle even sillier you've got a guy in
El Chapo with nearly an unlimited money
supply connections Royalists all over
the world the idea that a cartel is
going to be upended by a wall is
absolutely ridiculous Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is being ridiculed for her
comment but I actually think the most
important conversation to have here Pat
is that you can't have a serious
conversation about drug trafficking in
the United States without talking about
the war on drugs making drugs illegal
and the entire war on drugs industrial
complex is what fuels black markets and
the violence that comes with them and it
is precisely predictable that El Chapo
is what you would predict would happen
if you have a war on drugs the likes of
which the United States has been waging
in a failed way for decades at this
point yeah our priorities are entirely
in the wrong place if you want fewer
undocumented immigrants if you want
fewer drugs coming across the border one
solution would be to legalize and
regulate those drugs we also have to
take a look at visa overstays because
that that takes up a majority of how
people get into this country illegally
the wall is just a small portion of that
as a side note American law enforcement
can't even keep drugs out of our own
jails and prisons who in their right
mind thinks that a wall will keep them
out of the United States and this is you
know completely aside from all of the
other facts that we know including that
again most drugs are coming through
legal ports of entry smuggled rather
than in any place that a wart a border
wall would stop them but you know does
anyone believe that given our total
failure to keep drugs out of the prison
and jail system that a wall is going to
stop multinational cartels that are
extraordinarily well-funded just doesn't
pass the common sense or sniff test one
iota today's program brought to you in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka
is a great service that I use all the
time what they do is they take thousands
of
the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink Asst
I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber which I
listened to on bling cos they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a 7 day free trial by going to blink
Escom slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about 5 bucks a month that's be Li NK is
t.com /pa que mas